make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting back into Justice League
by by Scott Snyder again this is
actually an exceedingly important
storyline because what this does is
really sort of corralled together a lot
of the multiversal stuff that's been
going on in DC Comics up to this point
now there are really two stories that
take place in this one involves Martian
Manhunter which we'll explain because I
think for a lot of people the ending
seemed a little strange and a little
ambiguous but we'll clear all that up
and the second one of course is what the
Justice League itself now for Martian
Manhunter what he's doing is he's
actually sort of reading the brain waves
of a lot of Earth's inhabitants and
they're all talking about what's called
the cloaked man this man out there who
is appearing to them and then offering
them whatever it is that they need in
order to rally them to his cause or to
just set them on violence streets or
what-have-you and violence really seems
to be the name of the game in terms of
just like invoking all these crazy
actions by various individuals you know
running into places with guns different
things like that and the superheroes are
doing what they can to corral it all but
it really seems to be amping up more so
than in than any other time right like
for whatever reason people are just
pissed off all the time and it's kind of
interesting concept right you know
because it's like life's too short to be
pissed off all the time it's one of
these things worse like if the life that
you live leads to you constantly being
pissed off then your life probably sucks
but on the less you know it's it's
interesting because all these all these
evil actions all these terrible actions
are being invoked by Lex Luthor and
where the the idea of the cloaked man is
more of like a like a myth or something
like that that people claim to have seen
but or you know I've never actually seen
themselves there are some who have and
all fingers and all the signs that
Martian Manhunter is looking at they all
point directly to Lex Luthor now at this
point we switch over to the hot to the
House of Heroes now the house of Heroes
you know this is one of the cool things
this first appeared in Multiversity
number one back in 2014 now of course we
did cover that series but again this is
basically the multiverse well Justice
League the House of Heroes is a giant
satellite it used to be occupied by the
monitors and they were all basically
wiped out except for one but at the
moment right now
it was totally unoccupied by the time
the multiversal Justice League showed up
and they basically operate out there but
the House of Heroes serves two purposes
one is kind of a monitoring satellite
for the multiverse right if there's like
a multiverse or calamity that the
multiversal Justice League needs to
attend to or it's a giant meeting and
gathering place now there are some cool
faces that show up here of course we end
up having Wally West from Kingdom Come
who shows up here those are you guys who
recognized him you've got vampire Batman
then he got captain carrot captain
carrot I love captain carrot I love him
he's one of my favorite characters
he's one of my absolute favorite
characters in all of DC but all these
different superheroes have been called
together by Superman because he's
literally telling them the multiverse is
going to pieces right now because
everything that's happened with perpetuo
coming back the forger of worlds who's
joined the Justice League now they're
all basically on the hunt for the other
two sons of Perpetua they're on the hunt
for the monitor and they're on the hunt
for the anti-monitor that's what they're
looking for right now as well as one of
these things are basically Superman says
if you guys have seen them let us know
but also what's going on is that we have
basically everything going to pot right
like the multiverse is kind of
descending into chaos and madness on
earth there were all these individuals
out there who were basically teetering
on on insanity and are all just like
violently attacking each other or who
have just succumb to absolute anger 100%
of the time and so because that if
there's anything you can do to bring
that to an end then go for it right like
any steps that we can take to stem the
tide of the influence of Perpetua and
bringing the multiverse to madness chaos
and an absolute end our steps that we
should take but it's a cool little
moment because what is up going on here
is suddenly you end up having Martian
Manhunter again following the clues and
things like that ends up arriving at
this old house of Lex Luthor but it's
the Lex Luthor family house is the house
of Lionel Luthor the man I'm sorry it's
the house of a woman rather who is
visited by the cloaked man but he's met
by the arrival of Lionel Luthor and this
is kind of a cool thing right because
Lionel Luthor is supposed to be dead now
for those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with a lot of the changes that
have been going on in scott Snyder's
Justice League one of the things that
was hit on here and really one of the
things he did was reworked the origin of
of Martian Manhunter the way this played
out was that originally there was a guy
named doctor hurdle and doctor herbal
conducting an experiment had basically
brought Martian Manhunter to earth and
then Manhunter kind of explored and went
around then a visually became a hero and
his powers were given you know kind of
expanded and he basically became
Superman with telepathy and he was
afraid of fire and he could shape-shift
it's kind of how his character
progressed over the years but with what
Scott Snyder's been doing what he
basically established here is that
instead of it being like a guy named dr.
Errol who basically brought Martian
Manhunter to Earth that what ended up
happening is Martian Manhunter was
kidnapped from Mars as a baby or as a
child and brought to earth and basically
experimented on by Lionel Luthor the
father
Lexx and so with these kind of gruesome
experiments of psychological tortures
taking place Lex Luthor as a child
actually freed Martian Manhunter and
that's how we ended up going back out
into the world it's a cool little moment
here it's a cool little segment here in
terms of like the kind of reworked
origin of Martian Manhunter I actually
like it more than the other one why it's
just you know kind of an accidental
portal opens and here comes the Martian
yeah I like this one a lot better than
the old school origin totally ended up
learning it this is not actually Lionel
Luthor this is this is basically a maze
oh and that's Martian Manhunter has kind
of been caught in the clutches of a
professor Ivo now this is not a
stupendously huge thing it's a cool
little moment in terms of dr. Ivo
basically being crazy and kind of the
history that he and Martian Manhunter
have in the idea that what's going on
here is that a maze owes back as strong
as he ever was right if those you guys
don't know Amazo was designed by dr. Ivo
for the purpose of being able to
duplicate the powers of others right so
he's basically a Swiss Army not he's
like a God killer it's one of the it's
one of the coolest things it's kind of
cool to see him come back right because
for me like having a character out there
who can duplicate the powers of all the
other members of the Justice League and
then defeat them all makes them one of
the most interesting concepts out there
and the new 52
we got the Amazo virus and then
eventually that led into a maze Oh
proper but with regards to seeing him
reappear here there's not a whole lot do
and it's not a great big huge event
great big huge thing you know it would
be kind of interesting if it was but
it's just sort of a small little moment
to show that all the things that that
Martian Manhunter is going through and
really kind of progressing his story
towards its logical end but what this
does is it switches back over to the
Justice League now this is really where
one of the big things happen with
regards to this story that when the
leech shows up there of course with a
forger of the world having joined their
ranks and they essentially show up on
the planet nil what we end up finding
out is that this place is is essentially
the home of the monitor but what the
world forger does is he basically goes
through and says here's the history of
the multiverse like that like the
history of your universe just like that
and it follows suit so perfectly right
because when people have asked about the
crises and DC Comics crisis on Infinite
Earths
Infinite Crisis Final Crisis what I tell
them is that the first crisis crisis on
Infinite Earths
destroyed the multiverse that Infinite
Crisis brought it back albeit in a
different form with you know different
settings and whatnot and then Final
Crisis made the heroes aware of the fact
that the multiverse had returned that's
really what's going on here and that's
really what it is that the world for
sure is it is is explaining here you
know when they stumble across the path
of the monitor is kind of interesting
because he basically says like all these
things
are starkly different from the way that
they're supposed to be right like these
heroes they don't know what they've been
through they don't know about the first
crisis about crisis on Infinite Earths
they don't know that that happened
they've forgotten about Infinite Crisis
they've forgotten about Final Crisis now
again all this really seems to sort of
fit into the notion of the fact that dr.
Manhattan had white ten years away from
everyone's memories but remember
Superman is a special case right
Superman as he exists now is a blend
between the version of himself that
existed before before the events of
Flashpoint and the newer version that
came after flashpoint he recalls
everything that happened before the
flash screwed up time right so he knows
about about Final Crisis he knows about
the Infinite Crisis but nobody else does
and the question has to be asked why
hasn't he bothered to sit down and tell
anyone right I mean that's what I would
do it's these these cool little moments
these small little things that go on
because after this whole explanation is
is provided here the monitor asks very
well surely you remember what it meant
to die I mean you died during the events
of crisis on Infinite Earths and Barry
begins to sort of recollect that he
begins to recall like this kind of
feeling that he had when he died because
when that story originally happened in
1985 he did die
it wasn't until Grant Morrison wrote
Final Crisis that we ended up learning
that Barry had been stuck in the Speed
Force for 20 years he wasn't actually
dead but at the time that story was
written Barry Allen was dead he was gone
you know and it's so cool because the
monitors like they don't remember any of
this they don't remember any of this
stuff you know all these things happen
and they totally forgot about it you
know and so that's when that's when
really the world for sure says Ben help
us like come to our cause and help us
out help us find the anti-monitor help
us find the third brother and so that's
when the monitor says okay but that
means we're gonna have to go to the
planet Court now for those people who
were followers of Green Lantern and this
is a pretty significant moment because
remember the anti-monitor hails from
court because court exists in the
antimatter universe remember the monitor
and the anti-monitor are essentially
opposites to each other and so it makes
sense that they would come from from
universes with two different states of
matter two different types of matter
there but the other cool thing about
this is is again kind of switching over
to Martian Manhunter where he's with
with Hawkgirl and they're going through
and and you know where she saved him
from from professor Ivo trashing
everything in the office in everything
in that in that whole building including
including a Mazal she just like comes
running in with her mace and just like
smashes his head off and then like
Martian Manhunter rips his brain out
destroys it and then like they just they
just bring an end to dr. IVA like that's
basically the end of him and it's all
said and done we
of course that like dr. Ivo was never
here in the first place that he was just
basically a robot but again this seems
to indicate the idea that Lex Luthor is
working with dr. Ivo and presumably dr.
Ivo will end up joining the the Legion
of Doom but again kind of moving over to
Martian Manhunter following up with the
Hawkgirl
of course he's met by the arrival I
guess really this little holographic
image of Lexi essentially says I can
give you everything you're looking for
all you have to do is follow my
instructions and so per the instructions
of Lex Luthor and Martian Manhunter and
Hawkgirl fly out to the middle of
nowhere Martian Manhunter shuts her down
so she ends up basically passing out and
then this kind of dimensional doorway
opens up which was the original lab of
Lionel Luthor from the last Justice
League video that we had and then
basically is this huge explanation that
like everything I'm doing is for the
purpose of attaining power and trying to
achieve this perfect form once he
discovered this hoe tality at the very
beginning of Snyder's run running all
the way up until right now he's been
trying to achieve this perfect form now
what this means we'll find out as we get
closer to get further into this story
they're switching back over to to the
Justice League again we basically joined
the group in court and all the weaponers
have been totally eradicated now
remember the weaponers were weapons
creators but they were also basically
agents or at least people who were
forced to work for both the anti-monitor
and Sinestro when he ran the yellow
Lantern Corps the Sinestro Corps and so
because of that but once they arrived
here all the weaponers have essentially
been wiped out they've been totally
destroyed and and it's kind of crazy to
you because I guess their bodies were
drained of blood but there's this giant
symbol that's written on the ground in
the old Malthusian language the language
of the guardians of the universe and it
basically says don't follow me and
that's kind of the bonkers thing here
because what seems to have happened is
the anti-monitor has some kind of Leben
constructed and as i just don't follow
me or I'm probably going to destroy you
guys
and he killed all the weaponers after
they made that weapon now in truth this
is kind of the question here in terms of
the hierarchy of where these brothers
reside which one's the most powerful
because the the issue they have is well
the anti-monitor could be anywhere like
anywhere in the entirety of the
multiverse ittsan it's a needle in a
stack of needles there's no guessing
where it is that he could be they could
spend all eternity searching from one
universe to the next and never find it
of course what they need is the ability
to kind of track down antimatter energy
and I'm sure that form will come and
haunt but switching back over to this
discussion with Lex and and Martian
Manhunter what we end up learning here
is that in the early days when the
multiverse was created by perpetuate
like this existing multiverse as it
stands now in DC
comics when he was created by Perpetua
she had what were basically like what
she considered to be these perfect beams
these perfect organisms out there who
essentially made up her armies and so
she maintained her order by using these
beings to her disposal now when did I'm
happening is after the fall of Perpetua
these beams were split in half
one group became humanity the other half
became Martians and so as a result
unless that's one reason why Martians
look like humans is because they stem
from humans and so because of this what
Lex Luthor needs to achieve his perfect
form is Martian DNA and that's why he
brought Martian Manhunter here is to say
hey look merge your body with montt and
we'll become this perfect organism now
of course Martian Manhunter shoots it
down he's like that's ridiculous like
you're crazy you've basically lost your
mind
and then Lex's okay fine that's how it's
gonna be then that's how it's going to
be and so as a result he basically ends
up taking over a Martian Manhunter right
like what he says is like these machines
that I have here they were designed to
dampen your powers and to keep you from
being able to read my mind
we're also hacking into yours they were
they were learning how to basically like
subvert your tell or your telepathy and
then use it to our own ends and start
like riddling your body down so I can
literally absorb you Lex Luthor finds a
way to overpower Martian Manhunter and
then absorb them into himself and then
achieve this this perfect form it's kind
of bonkers to see right like now what
this means going forward we don't know
because we don't know what kind of
enhancements these offer we don't really
know if Martian Manhunter is truly dead
but we don't know if like if Lex Luthor
can walk around with like telepathy and
shape-shifting and all these things or
if those powers just aren't really
available to him and instead he just has
enhanced strength and durability or
something along those lines right
because Lex Luthor is already a super
genius now being able to like elevate
his consciousness to like cosmic
awareness or being able to elevate his
his intelligence to like super high
levels maybe that'll present itself in
time but at the moment he's just kind of
like this absolute perfect being is
really what he is and so as a result of
this when the Justice League is met by
the arrival of Lex Luthor's Legion of
Doom what they end up saying is like we
have to get out of here and we're
members of the League wanna stay and
fight jobs through his responses no no
no I have you guys protected with my
Green Lantern ring but if like if we can
discover if we get into a fight with
these guys my ring is gonna run dry
basically we're gonna ride a juice and
when that happens I will not protect you
and so essentially you're gonna be a
positive matter human in an antimatter
universe you're going to explode you'll
cease to exist you'll basically die and
so like the only option we have here is
to leave this place is to get out of
here is
as we possibly can it's a really really
smart move because what this does that's
one of the reasons why it is that that
semester of chose to operate in court
one because he was banished there the
two while he could have left and made
his way back to the to the main BC
universe what this meant was that he
could operate inside the negatives oh
I'm sorry I saw the antimatter of
universe and not have to worry about
being disturbed because people can't
readily access that place they can't
just get in a ship and fly there because
if they don't take the right precautions
they're gonna end up dying it's a great
safe haven it's a great place to stay
hidden away from everything so that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end it's an awesome story I
love with Snyder's doing with Justice
League so far I think it's one of the
best stories coming out of DC Comics
will it be said we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain to make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]